fourth and fifth in London we are going
to have the biggest minecraft
celebration in the world at Minecon 2015
we can't wait to share more with the
community there and be inspired by their
ideas we're always trying to harness new
technology and create new ways of
playing the game with that in mind
please let me welcome sax person from
Microsoft Studios and we're excited to
be able to show a new version of
Minecraft built specifically for
microsoft hololens Thank You Lydia to
show a demo today we're using a special
camera this display technique is like
putting a hololens right on the camera
itself allowing the entire audience to
see the holograms now this is a live
demo with real working code that's your
what it can do you can play the
Minecraft you know today on hololens sax
grabbed his Xbox controller to play
through a giant holographic portal into
a 3d Minecraft world right on the wall
even though I don't have a hololens I'm
able to play together with sax from my
surface are you gonna come join my game
Lydia I'm in now I see you jumping
around one of the cool things about
hololens is that it lets you display
Minecraft virtually anywhere you can get
different perspectives on your Minecraft
world it's awesome to play with the
controller but could we show them
something new sax sure
let's take AI experience off the wall
and then put it on the table over here
create world
I see Lydia way up there as I run around
and play sax can easily navigate and
manipulate the world using his voice and
his hands he can walk around the
hologram pan around four different
viewpoints and even look inside let's
follow Lydia around for a bit follow
player I can zoom in and out for a
better perspective closer all the way in
close-up what are you up to Lydia I'm
hopping in a minecart let's take a ride
down to the village we're gonna pick a
different perspective overview
it's incredibly cool down minecraft on
your table imagine seeing your own
worlds like this isn't it crazy that I
see sacks just standing at the table but
through the hololens he can see a whole
Minecraft universe at his fingertips you
can even raise the entire world and see
things that are normally hidden way
underneath the ground could you give us
a sneak peek of what's under that
village stacks sure
grab the world lift it up let's see
what's hiding underneath Lydia loo huge
stronghold right underneath I'm gonna
mark that for you mark that are you
gonna have to find a way to break in I
see it I'm on my way there now I'm
placing some TNT so I can blow my way
into this stronghold I could use a light
though Sachs good strategy using
hololens i have access to all console
commands and minecraft just using my
boys but i can just focus my gaze on the
tnt and say lightning strike step back
whoa there's a lot of materials down
there i wouldn't have seen without you
what's one more thing i want to do with
lightning see a pigpen over here i think
the pigs need an upgrade lightning
strikes
there you have it zombie pigmen